In addition to choosing
major breakpoints,
where layout changes significantly,
it's also helpful to add minor
breakpoints to make some small changes.
For example, between major breakpoints,
it may be helpful to adjust margins and
paddings on an element.
Or to increase the font size to make
things, a little bit easier to read and
feel more natural in the layout.
In this case let's boost the font, when
the viewport width is between 400 and
550 pixels,
where our break point kicks in.
I'll also separate the low and
high temperature, so
that they're not on the same line and
make the weather icons bigger as well.
Let's switch to the source and
I'll add a media query that's applied,
when the viewport is between 450 and
550 pixels.
It ups the base font,
changes the low and
high temperature to be inline block,
and increases the icon size.
I'll save the file, and
then take a look in the browser.
Sure enough, my icons are now bigger,
my fonts are now bigger, and
everything looks like I expect it to.
In this before and after, you can
see how things have really changed.
The icons are much bigger,
the font sizes have also changed, and
the minimum and maximum temperatures are
now shown in a slightly different way.
For larger view ports I want to limit
the maximum width of the forecast page.
Panel, so that it doesn't consume
the entire view port as it gets wider.
I already have a link style sheet
with min-width query of 700 pixels.
So in there, I just need to
set some margins and padding.
Let's take a look.
I'll set the width to 700 pixels,
and set margin left and
margin right to auto.
I'll come back to Chrome, hit Refresh,
and now we've got what I want.
There you have it.
You can use minor break points,
to adjust the little things and
really make things shine.